And finally I'd like to show you this
illustration from Intel that summarizes
the advances in the Intel VT
architecture over the last decade or so.
The lowest set of boxes
summarize the impact
of the virtualization related
hardware modifications that have been
added along the three
different dimensions.
The three dimensions are as follows,
vector 1,
refers to any CPU related
modifications and
this includes things like fixing issues
with non-virtualizable instructions or
adding support to the CPU for
extended page tables.
Vector 2, refers to modifications
pertaining to the entire chipset,
such as chipset site support for
technologies like what's called SR-IOV,
that technologies that help with IO
virtualization, or for IO routing and
mechanisms for direct device access, or
support rather for direct device access.
And then the third vector,
the third dimension in which
Intel has contributed to the evolution
of virtualization friendly technology,
is to actually push advances in
the device level technology.
So this is what's happening on the
device as opposed to on the chip you,
on the chipset or the CPU side.
And with this draws
devices are more easily
integrated in a virtualized environment.
This includes things like support
on the device for DMA remapping so
that it can appropriately
DMA into the correct set of
memory depending on the virtual
machine that it targets.
And to also support the multiple queue,
the multiple logical interfaces
such that different logical interface
can be given to a different VM.
The architecture versions that
encapsulate these modifications
are referred to as VT-x for the
modifications along the first vector.
With a VT-x2, VT-x3 occurring in
subsequent generations of processors.
Then VT-d for the advances along the
second dimension with VT-d following and
so forth, and then the architecture
modifications along the third vector
are encapsulated into what's referred to
as IOVs or IO virtualization technology.
And VMDq what stands for
virtual machine device queue's, so
this is device residence support.